AGITATORS OUT THERE ARE IN FULL
FORCE AND WANT TO ATTACK HIM NO
MATTER WHAT.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN BYRON
DONALDS.
WE LIVE IN A WOKE WORLD,
CONGRESSMAN.
WE LIVE IN A WORLD OF CANCEL
CULTURE, RIGHT?
HOW COME THE ONE OPENINGS TO
THAT IS BLACK CONSERVATIVES
WHERE IT'S OPEN SEASON.
THIS IS REPULSIVE.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST ATTACK
AGAINST YOU.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, EVERY
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE
THAT I KNOW GOES THROUGH SOME
FORM OF THIS.
WHY IS IT TOLERATED?
BECAUSE IT SHOULDN'T BE
TOLERATED.
>> WELL, I MEAN, LOOK, SEAN, I
THINK IT'S TOLERATED FROM THE
LEFT BECAUSE BLACK
CONSERVATIVES, WE DEMONSTRATE A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT WORLDVIEW
THAN THE STUFF THAT THE LEFT AND
THE DEMOCRATS LIKE TO PUT OUT
BUT TO BE HONEST, I'M ACTUALLY
SICK AND TIRED OF TALKING ABOUT
THIS KIND OF STUFF.
THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE MY STAFF
AND I KIND OF GOT TOGETHER, AND
THEY FELT SO STRONGLY ABOUT
TALKING ABOUT THIS BECAUSE,
SEAN, WHAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW IS I HAVE BLACK STAFFERS
AND I HAVE WHITE STAFFERS.
THOUGH COME TOGETHER, THEY WORK
HARD FOR ME AND MY CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND I REALLY FEEL BAD FOR THEM
AND THE OTHER YOUNG BLACK PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO ARE STARTING TO
BECOME MORE CONSERVATIVE.
WHAT STUFF LIKE THIS IS ABOUT IS
ABOUT STOPPING THEM FROM
EXPRESSING THEIR POLITICAL
THOUGHTS, THEIR POLITICAL WORLD
VIEWS.
FOR ME, I'M A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
I'LL DEAL WITH THE HOT TAKES AND
THE SHOTS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I
SIGNED UP FOR.
BUT FOR OTHER BLACK PEOPLE IN
AMERICA WHO ARE STARTING TO COME
AROUND TO CONSERVATISM AND A
LIMITED GOVERNMENT PHILOSOPHY
THIS KIND OF STUFF IS TO
SUPPRESS THEIR THOUGHTS AND
THEIR VIEWPOINTS, AND I'M SAD
FOR THEM BECAUSE THAT SHOULDN'T
BE TOLERATED IN AMERICA.
>> HANNITY: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THE DEBT CEILING.
WE HAVE, WHAT, 33 TRILLION IN
DEBT.
IT IS NOT AN IMMINENT CRISIS.
WE COULD PROBABLY GO A NUMBER OF
MONTHS, MAYBE EVEN UNTIL JUNE.
HOWEVER, IT'S COMING.
IT'S PENDING.
MY HOPE IS REPUBLICANS WILL HAVE
A PLAN, STAY UNITED.
WILL THAT HAPPEN?
>> YES, THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A PLAN ON
THIS.
WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE HAS PUT OUT
THERE SAYING THERE WILL BE NO
NEGOTIATIONS, THAT'S JUST
INSANE.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE AT ALL.
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IS
MAKING SURE AT A MINIMUM THAT WE
GET RID OF ALL THIS COVID
SPENDING OUT OF THE BASELINE.
THAT WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
BRINGING SOME SPENDING RESTRAINT
BACK TO WASHINGTON, D.C., AND
THEN WE HAVE TO START COMING UP
WITH OTHER STRATEGIES BECAUSE
JUST CONTINUOUSLY GOING TO
EXPANDING THE CREDIT CARD IS NOT
GOING TO BE WHAT'S IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A PLAN.
WE'RE GOING TO STAND TOGETHER
AND DO WHAT'S RIGHT ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA.
>> HANNITY: YOU ABSOLUTELY HAVE
BECOME A RISING STAR IN THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSERVATIVE